Okay, so one.
>> See, now that was mean. So right, one is an
epsilon, no because epsilon has to be less than or equal
to half, we already said that, but you're right. In a
sense setting epsilon to one, is always a valid answer to
the question, find an epsilon set that we've epsilon exhausted the
version space. Because all it's saying is, that there is nothing
left in the set that has an error greater than one.
And since the error is defined to be the probability, it can't
be greater than one. So that was kind of you know, kind of rude.
>> All right, I, I thought I just answered the
question. But I guess you want me to give you [CROSSTALK]
>> Yeah but you, but you prob-, what you probably should
have pointed out is that I left out the word smallest.
>> Oh! Yes, yes. Okay. Well, so, I don't know the answer
to that but, I think I could walk through it very quickly.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so you saying the ones that are
in green are the training examples that we see, right?
>> Right.
>> So we should be able to use that
to figure out what the version space actually is.
>> Right, which we did in a previous question.
>> Right, although I don't remember [LAUGH] what the answer was.
>> I'll remind you.
>> I'll remind you,It's okay. So it was x1
>> Mh-hm.
>> Right, because the x1 matches, it was, or and x or.
>> I think that was it.
>> Yeah, I think that's right. Okay, so, then what we can do is
given that those are the three things
that we've done. We could actually compute,
what the error is according to this distribution for each of those three.
>> Yes, exactly so.
>> So let's, let's start with X1. So which one, x1, so all three
of those are going to get the first one and the third one correct, right?
>> All of them are going to get the first
one and the third one correct. Yes, by design.
>> By design.
>> Right, to be in the version space.
>> So now we can ask which ones will get the second one wrong?
The fourth one doesn't matter because it has zero probability of showing up.
>> That's right. So, it doesn't matter if you get this one
right or wrong, it's not going to contribute to this true error measure.
>> Okay. So let's look at x one. So x one will in fact get the
second one wrong, because the output Is not the same as the value for x one.
>> Good. And so what;s the probablity that x one, this hypothesis
x one, is going to give a wrong answer on a randomly drawn input?
>> Well,
half the time it will get the second answer,
and so the error is, in fact, one half.
>> Yes. Exaclty. Good. All right. Let's move on to the or.
>> Okay. So, we can do an easy one actually. We can do x or. Since we know
x or is the right answer, we know It
will has a probablity of being wrong of zero.
>> Oh, good point.
>> Okay. And so for or we can do the same thing. So is, we know it's going to
get the first and the third ones right. So
now we can ask whether it's going to get the
second one, right. And zero or one is in fact true.
Or one. So in fact it also has an error of zero.
>> Okay.
>> Which is kind of interesting. So and so,
even though the function is xor, if we can
get to the point where we have or or
xor left, we actually will get zero true error.
>> That's right.
>> But in the meantime, because x1 has still
survived the two examples that we have. Epsilon is
therefore 0.5.
>> Right, in particular, we're saying that, this
is, if, if epsilon were smaller than 0.5,
then it wouldn't be epsilon exhausted because you'd
have a hypothesis that has error that's too high.
>> Right.
>> So this is the smallest epsilon that we can use.
And in fact, we let you through if if it was anything
0.5 to, to one, but this is the, this is the
value that I was really hoping you'd be able to reason out.
>> Okay, well that all made sense.
>> Good, nice work.
>> Thanks.